[Musik]
hi-angriffe machen Schlagzeilen in New
York am Rock away beach in Queens wird
eine 65-jährige Schwimmerin schwer
verletzt schon der fünfte bis an New
Yorker Stränden diesen Sommer
am beliebten Jones Beach hat die Polizei
die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen erhöht die
Marineeinheit sucht das Wasser nach
Heinen ab
nirgendwo gab es letztes Jahr mehr
high-angriffe als in den USA 41 von 57
weltweit davon 8 in New York der
Bundesstaat steht an zweiter Stelle
hinter Florida
wir haben immer mehr heilsichtungen und
heilbisse
wir fahren jetzt viel öfter mit dem Boot
raus und setzen mehr Drohnen ein um die
Schwimmer zu schützen
während die Marine auf dem Boot
patrouliert überwachen Hubschrauber und
Drohnen das Wasser aus der Luft die
Bilder werden in Echtzeit in einen
mobilen Kommandowagen Übertragen von wo
aus weitere Maßnahmen koordiniert werden
Joes reach
Drohnen sind sehr gut um uns bei der
Suche nach gefährlichen Meerestieren zu
helfen erlauben den Blick von oben
zur hai-überwachung damit kann die
Polizei mit Opfern im Wasser über
lautsprecherkontakt aufnehmen und sogar
Schwimmwesten abwerfen
über Kameras halten sie nach Anzeichen
für Raubfische Ausschau
wir suchen nach großen Schwärmen von
Fischen so können wir eindeutige
Anzeichen für Haie erkennen wenn sie
Fischschwärme jagen zum Beispiel eine
Flosse oder eine kreisförmige Bewegung
wenn die Haie zum Angriff übergehen
diese Fischschwärme dienen den Haien als
Nahrung und locken sie näher an die
Küsten und Strände Forscher der
gemeinnützigen Organisationen
untersuchen das Verhalten der Tiere
sie nehmen Blut und Gewebeproben Ring
Sender an den Flossen an um Ihre
Bewegungen zu beobachten über die
Website
shark-stube verschiedene Haiarten
darunter auch der weiße Hai die
Jungtiere könnten für einige der
Angriffe von New York verantwortlich
sein muss sie ist kein Suppe
bei den meisten dieser Bisse vor allem
in New York handelt es sich um eine Art
Verwechslung viele dieser jungen Haie
sind nicht sehr erfahren und beißen in
das falsche
Fangnetze zum Schutz von Schwimmern
setzt man in New York nicht ein man will
Haie und andere Meerestiere nicht
verletzen
sollte ein Hai angreifen gibt es Hilfe
direkt vor Ort
Rettungsschwimmer auf Jetskis können
Opfer in wenigen Minuten mit einer Trage
aus dem Wasser retten
seit ich 1975 der weiße Hai gesehen habe
habe ich Angst vor ihnen aber sie leben
nun mal hier es ist schlimm wenn etwas
passiert aber es ist eher
unwahrscheinlich es wird mich nicht
davon abhalten ins Wasser zu gehen
Meeresbiologen sehen die Haie von New
York auch als ein positives Signal für
erfolgreichen Umweltschutz das Wasser
ist sauberer die Fischschwärme kommen
zurück als spitzenprellatoren und Heil
für das Gleichgewicht des Ozeans wichtig
es ist unsere Verantwortung zu verstehen
dass es sich um einen wilden Ort handelt
an dem Heil Leben und an dem wir sie
auch haben wollen
die Menschen müssen lernen mit den Haien
zu koexistieren die New Yorker Strände
wussten daher auf bereiten sich auf eine
gemeinsame Zukunft mit Heim vor